good evening everyone along with any old
Jack Mike Emmerich the Eastern
Conference is our focus for this evening
is there a difference in the play in the
East I believe there is Dhaka I think
it's more defensive style I think it's
more zone to zone so meeting station a
station so defensive zone to the neutral
zone then eventually to the offensive
zone The Devil's thought process must be
on the road is to keep the game simple
move the puck from the D zone to the
neutral zone and eventually into the
offensive zone looking to get a big two
points here as the visitor let's look at
the starting net minders Sergei Bob Roth
ski from Russia a first all-star and
winner of the pheasant a trophy in 2012
mainstay goalie for Columbus and the
Russian Olympic team important and he
starts this one Cory Schneider gets the
start developed with the u.s. national
team then Boston College then the
American Hockey League then Vancouver
then with the legend Marty Brodeur he's
learned his trade well
another terrific night of hockey here
tube in skis the faceoff man for the
Blue Jackets and rates out there to try
to beat him for New Jersey opening
faceoff up this contest has been taken
gets in what'll he do let it go
that's what those pads are for fast cut
strong play
and they've got it again point-to-point
pass from the left-wing tape to tape to
say
Nino's Rashad was heavy and quick really
good shot as you mentioned and so
quickly delivered the goalie can't get
his arm up over quick enough to block
her this into the corner
Columbus is scored first will they be
the team that builds on it with the next
goal or not
solid win at center ice now what to say
nod off and you're all alone in front of
the goaltender's from this area of the
ice great save
now it's directed to Camilleri
all's cut through the neutral zone
and he's all along oh that's a great
save by barosky
Snyder's athleticism was tested on that
wrist shop that was an excellent scoring
chance a little under 4 minutes play
it's a one-nothing game new jersey's
pick on the draw
got a stick on it the Blue Jackets are
carrying at their own zone games the
blue line
the shooter thought he'd made a pretty
good shot here but the goaltender's in
good shape he makes the stop and he's
able to deny the shooter on what he
thought was an excellent chance
the Blue Jackets win it Keith
Johnson scores on that slap shot it
looked like it was shot out of a 10 now
you do your bestest you can get in front
of it but that is just too quick a shot
for the goaltender
they won the faceoff directing that one
to fiddler check my actions Tamara
standing save difficult opportunity we
don't get many better opportunities than
that great shades good Jenna ray sticks
a
any holds on
Snyder's ability to read the play was
pretty good there as he got across to
make the stop on that odd man rush
defensive zone wins looking to Fiddler's
to Palmeri
and angle tomorrow oh that one hit
someone on the way pelvic sailing but he
can't get off the ice is gonna have to
try and finish the ship that's one way
to stop the bull Madam's cover the
pocket get a whistle
it's displayed some courage after being
banged up earlier in the shift still
gets itself into the shooting lane to
block the shot just over eight minutes
gone here in the first the Blue Jackets
just widen their lead it's now too
quick work on the face-off
weights from the corner shoes Josh
missed the net with that one he was
trying to be a little bit too fine there
that's why he missed the net say
Columbus leaves its own end
he's got it he's held to the glass [ __ ]
is thrown to Bashar
the stick broke undershot and possession
has changed
brilliant move on that pass great save
Point Blank not a lot of room to score
from in that area great save behind the
net laid on to Hartnell blocked
trying to go to marry any recovers still
with it
gets in and he'll look over his options
good stick down on the ice so nothing
good happening there
it was pretty easy this low on the slide
just snap it home
Snyder's moved to the stick side is
pretty aggressive but he doesn't get
there quick enough to stop the shot
they've got the draw snapping a pass to
halt oh that's nice cut pass let's see
what happens
Columbus truth stick players forced a
lot of turnovers away covers and a
faceoff will follow well he took a
pretty good jolt there guys that shot
caught him right in the mask we'll have
to watch him for the next few minutes
see if it affects the way that he plays
a little under six minutes remaining
here in the period the Blue Jackets just
keep building on that earlier lead their
advantage is three
slides it to the point to Jones not
through hammers and in a good job in the
goal crease passing one off now to haul
a shot
a magnificent pass a into the attacking
end
please ik turned aside and the puck
taken over by Mike Cammalleri
fires a shot freezes play
the broth skis athleticism is on display
it's an odd-man rush against excellency
we go down to the benches here's ray
work from the home teams locker room is
there going to be short a player for the
rest of the night the injury occurred a
while ago he will not return
Kerry toward the neutral zone Columbus
moves with it up the wing on side chip
ba great save there not much
got a good shot away you wanna score
goals you have to go to this area you
got to find a way to put it into net
you can't ask much more from your
goaltender than this that's an excellent
wrist shot that he's able to come on
New Jersey's got a faceoff win to
Palmieri employee inside the final
minute of play pass attempt to Zajac
wonderful play by the defense
the devil's up the wing are moving the
puck a shot passe
first trade has ended in a strong early
lead has been built